citizens of the reject Nation I'm Tara
Erickson joined by my close to your
personal friends I see your name I'm
John oh what's your last name John's
Humphrey oh right I I forgot I didn't
really forget I just wanted him to see
it listen guys we're watching The Maze
Runner from 2014. that's from a long
time ago yeah almost 10 years I did not
read the book I don't think uh if I did
I cannot remember it but we're gonna
watch it and it's gonna be fun so you
guys need to leave a like you know what
to do you need to get on the computer
type the words leave a comment and then
you also have to subscribe and by doing
that you can bring the Bell
yes also thanks to prepper for adding
down this reaction video and don't
forget if you're not already a patron
you should become one because if you are
then you can sync up with your own copy
and watch a full-length reaction with me
and John like the whole thing where
we're sitting we're reacting we're doing
stuff you can watch it with us with your
own very full length copy and then also
we call you super sexy
also Greg and John cover several shows
exclusively over there with highlights
and watch alongs in colluded so like get
on the juice come on now get on the
juice okay just do it
and I think that's it should we just
like watch it let's just watch it okay
man let's do it
foreign
are we going
down or up oh
yes not feeling well
it's a Dylan O'Brien
hey that's a guy from Love and monsters
oh and there's a monster
this is how every one of my days begins
day one granny Rising shot
Will Poulter oh whoa
hey we gotta run
[Applause]
a Maze Runner mayhaps
still trying to figure out what the f is
going on oh okay it's their first day at
an all boys high school he's stuck
oh okay was that like the version of
hazing that was their version of hey
they're like throw them in that elevator
with that spooky elevator yeah my name
is zombie you tell me anything about
yourself Who You Are where you came from
Alby the racist dragon
why can't I remember it it's okay it
happens to us all you get your name back
in a day or two what it's a powerful
anesthetic we grow our own food
build our own shelter whatever we need
the Box provides the Box provides
a big old box
send them once a month with fresh
supplies in the new Greenie I who though
who put us here and now we don't know
green bean no I love him when I'm not
around he's in charge this is spinach
the boy from Love Actually is so grown
up now and I think he's on Game of
Thrones too to be fair oh yeah chojin
something what's up there never gonna be
on those walls do you understand me
Greenie yes carrots what happens behind
the walls everybody wants to know hey
Chuck
excellent nice these are those same
pants
haven't been washed where where are you
going
I just want to see
kilogram all you want but you better not
go out there I just know what I'm told
I'm not supposed to leave where's your
sense of adventure Chuck he pooped his
pants too many times he doesn't have
Adventures anymore
negrini huh how does it feel to be
promoted hey they were just for outside
they break breaking rules they're
different they're Runners they know more
about the maze than anyone what you just
said maze
I did oh chuck oh you're done messed up
now chuck chuck doesn't have a vault why
won't you tell me what's out there
trying to protect you man for your own
good you guys can't just keep me here I
can't let you leave why not he's doing
the Chris Pratt hand
[Laughter]
stay where you are blue
oh what
uh awesome I would like to go out now
this is pretty intriguing so far
it's a metaphor
crushed by circumstance
welcome to the Glade
the Glade or the blade I still don't
know what they're saying yeah they're
interchangeable
sure there are plenty of blades in the
Glade
all right bonfires
where'd you get that cow head or horse
head or whatever that is the skull we're
trapped here
for the moment
how's the runners
that guy in the middle there
that's Mina
the coolest one they run the maze
memorizing it trying to find a way out
how long have they been looking
three years oh my God that's too long
but yeah
it's amazing
changing oh
this is some sick psycho ward
they're all watching you yeah you're all
Lab Rats Runners are the only ones that
really know what's out there and it's a
good thing too because if they don't
make it back before those doors close
then they're stuck out there for the
night how many of you lost no one's ever
survived the night oh but you will you
got this Dylan O'Brien yeah man you're
the greeny they never saw it coming what
happened
or we call them Grievous of course no
one's ever
seen one and live to tell about it
Grievers good why a novel terminology
no no one wants to be a runner and
besides you don't get chosen if chosen
by who the jerk guy you don't like now
fight and show you're worthy
what do you say Greenie wanna see What
You're Made Of yes creamy greeny greeny
greeny greeny greeny the rules are
simple Greenie
I'm trying to push you out of the circle
try to last more than five seconds
ready
[Applause]
he's not doing so hot what do you want
to be called
Shank
[Applause]
you are too funny I think I'm settled on
Shank
it's better than radish that's what I
can get him oh
boy nice
now you've done it you've upset the
structure you upset the hierarchy man
Thomas what
oh that's my name I remember my name I'm
Thomas
[Music]
all right
Tommy Boy
I've never seen that either I do love
how every single y novel adaptation does
have like a sequence where they take a
break to dump all the new terminology on
you yeah these guys are called the this
and those are called the that yeah
dang
oh that's spooky we lost a lot of boys
to fear
Panic we've come far since then
established order
why are you telling me this
because you're not like the others and
the audience needs to know that
you're curious
he was there for five like five minutes
oh oh
no oh boy okay or George they don't even
try and climbing in the top yes anything
you think of we've already tried the
only way out here is through the maze
now look you want to be helpful yes
obviously
I guess that's some more fertilizer some
late Reflex on that catch
what do we got bones
oh great
damn
they did not bury that body very well
and George must not have died in The
Maze
oh
oh he looks so good buddy
Ben right I don't know if we uh ever
what the oh my God what are you okay
what
oh damn oh my gosh she's
I saw you
your fault what
that's right yes oh no who
a
some heavy stunts in this game not gonna
lie this kind of going hard yeah
definitely help what the fudge oh my
goodness oh
[Applause]
oh
stung by a griever contact with a
griever he's been stuck in the middle of
the day we gotta put him down
put him in the pit come on everybody
I'm pretty sure he's gonna be able to
break out of that pit I wonder what it
must have been like to be some of the
other people
hanging out in the field all day
shooting he said he saw me
you know this is all my fault how could
this be my fault
let's get some rest what do you know
oh just please listen to me please
man sorry dude that's hardcore
[Music]
they're just gonna like send them out oh
no please please don't please don't do
it oh you're gonna become one of them
buddy you gotta go oh they're gonna have
to push him with those tea sticks yeah
[Music]
uh yep here we go
cheese man awkward
just run buddy just go just accept your
fate get out of there you don't want to
be squished to death yeah you're gonna
get smushed come on run oh what are you
doing
oh my God
oh hey okay so he accepted smooshing as
his fate or uh well he just didn't want
to go take his chances with the maze
he's right there okay he doesn't want to
get soft-fived right now you think he
might make it he did
survives the night in the maze
you don't know that man yeah you haven't
been out there Chuck
oh here we go another dreamy or a memory
oh a memory a lady is that Wicked is
good
oh for a second I thought that was
Kirsten Stewart it's not I thought it
was um the one from get out two and
Megan or Kate Mar she looks like a bunch
of people
Tunes
what do they put in your jeans man give
you some kind of griever repellent Juju
my volunteers tribute
why would Aldi go in the Maze I'll be
went to retrace Ben's footsteps before
Sundown so he's gonna go back to where
Ben was just starting he knows what he's
doing he knows better than any of us
until he doesn't come back tonight every
month the Box sends up a new arrival
someone had to be first right
it's Alby first
that was Alby oh it begins with a yeah
this is the future the feminists want
all the men in one compound can't leave
monsters outside they should be back by
now what happens if they don't make it
they're gonna make it this is what they
do it's part of the show right at the
last minute or they won't and you guys
will be worried all night are they dead
or not can't we send someone after them
that's against the rules
can't risk losing anyone else
I mean you're kind of risking losing all
of you by standing at the mouth but yeah
I'm around at the last second here we go
somebody's injured oh no okay hurry
oh God this is a close call
uh leave him
go in Dylan O'Brien
you have to leave him
so he's gonna help it's all up to you
that greeny's gonna do it
yeah
how are you gonna oh it closed oh dang
oh snap oh my goodness what are they
gonna do
what happened to us
it looked like
okay he's a Graver now
get him up
this is already changing just leave them
here the old rules don't apply green
bean I mean he's dead so take his vest
pack and get going
there's not a single place we can take
him take a look around
there's nowhere to go
well I feel like there's a lot of
hallways in a maze around you you just
try something
cover him up with the vines or what are
we thinking or climb wow
okay
still think it was a really bad choice
not taking his vest off him and using
his weapons yeah a little bit but if he
wakes up he'll need to defend himself
whilst mortally wounded what are you
doing
[Music]
what the all right buddy leave him in a
Lurch yeah he knows the maze yeah he's
got time for this green bean oh
is he just gonna like all right
camouflage up in there
oh what is this thing is it What organic
or mechanical yeah it looks metal to me
heavy metal
I mean the soundscape alone in here is
quite jarring yeah very freaked out in
here
[Music]
spooky is it like a spider looks like a
robo spider
oh gross that looks like a Harry Potter
spider yeah
no
I swooping camera movements
[Applause]
oh Wowie
oh my God
online boy
oh whoa whoa nice jump oh
how does this work
[Music]
s faith
did the same people like engineer these
creatures
oh nice
you could be the first two to make it
back here
that trust your instincts
[Music]
oh yeah what if he like I was thinking
that like what if he just stays in there
and then crushes the spider but he gets
out right on time yeah
yeah smart that's what oh god
yeah yeah yeah oh oh oh oh oh good good
good good come on buddy you got this
no way
yeah
this is just like yesterday you saw a
griever you can just see it
killed it
oh man oh greeny King green beans yeah
for three years we have coexisted with
these things
and now you've killed one of them you
call it coexisting he has to be punished
what you don't even know if you're gonna
get backlash for the spider dying yet
buddy when I turned tail and ran
this dumb shank stood behind to help
Alby look I don't know if he's Brave or
stupid yes both
whatever it is we need more of it
I say we make him a runner yeah now
we're talking the subtle version of one
of my favorite tropes we need more
around like that around here you're
hired but if there was one thing that I
know about the maze it is that you do
not
[Music]
it's moving at a different time right
everything's changing man okay
it's coming back up it should have been
uh oh
just Jump Right In
what oh oh no oh God no this is not good
is that his mom or something that's the
girl who was in the thing with him
in his memory
oh
okay last Greenie the last one ever to
oh yeah she knows who he is my name is
also Thomas You're Gonna Go on dissect
that thing all by yourself I will if I
have to the other one who's left yet the
other Runners quit this morning also ask
about where's your vest yeah I'm
supposed to get a vest I think it's time
we find out what we're really up against
you're not going back out there
out there looking me in the woods in
half an hour
all right man and bring my vest yeah
this be enough
okay
all right you got a squad now stepping
up
awesome
what
oh okay
oh
something in there you mean besides a
group of pancake
I take the computer out a camera
that red blinky light is it still
recording all right ready on three one
two three
oh
that thing's coming okay
what the hell is that
wckd same as on the crate in the
elevator oh this is the same that as we
get in our supplies who knows where this
might lead us you see what he's trying
to do right we should punish him oh my
God Mike's freaking guy put this guy in
the pit the rules are the only thing
that have ever held us together why now
are we questioning that and kept you in
this big box too starting from tomorrow
you're a runner I mean it seems like the
logical conclusion he's the first one to
kill a Graver and he came back with
Clues like why are you so mad bro yeah
like just go cook dinner and chill it's
unprecedented circumstances man come on
yeah like at least a little flexibility
from you yeah
Beckham
eighth of the way not at all
we must be punished
please tell me there's like an
initiation ayahuasca ceremony oh my gosh
I think you're right what is this thing
oh that's what they've carved all the
sequences of the maze
then maybe the the letters and the
numbers is the sequence of the Maze and
how to get out
I think maybe or not I don't know
no you're right
what do you mean all of it I thought you
were still mapping it there's nothing
left to map hmm oh
why haven't you told anyone this it was
obvious call people needed to believe we
had a chance of getting out but maybe
now we do we have a real chance
printing on the walls sections one
through eight when the maze changes it
opens up a new section the pattern
always stays the same
okay and that one's from Seven that's so
special about seven
last night when you killed that griever
section seven was open tomorrow you and
I are going to take a closer look yeah
with Seth Meyers those are awesome
girls are awesome
it's true one more of those things
I don't think she likes us very much hey
look we just want to talk
we got a hell of rocks up there yeah
like where'd she get all those racks
okay I'm gonna come up okay
hmm
just me he's gonna explode yeah stay
back buddy is there nothing this green
bean can't do
where am I this is all normal yeah we've
all been through this your name that'll
come back to you in a couple of days
it's like this the one thing that's true
oh yeah just like she remembered you she
got it quick girls mature faster
are you sure you don't remember anything
else I remember water feeling like I was
drowning these faces staring at me do
you remember that too Thomas woman's
voice saying the same thing over and
over Wicked is Good Wicked is good she's
from Boston she's just trying to explain
the slang
Wicked is good you were there there we
go these were in my pocket when I came
up
a T Virus Wicked is good maybe it's an
antidote for a reason for when you get
stung we don't even know what this stuff
is we don't know who sent it why it came
up here with you I mean for all we know
that this thing could kill it well I
mean look at him how could this possibly
make it any worse
don't accidentally prick yourself
oh my God you better stab him quick
oh my God hurry up Jesus goodness
gracious
oh what do you got there oh that came
out pretty damn big oh that's what he's
been carving the whole time it's for my
parents you remember your parents must
have them it could be a test tube baby
why would you give this to me grandma
my best friend maybe if you find a way
out you can give it some for me this
kid's a good actor I want to Chuck a lot
me too
I want you to give that to them yourself
when we get out of here we're gonna get
out of here
all of us
I promise oh buddy big day Greenie sure
you don't want to sit this one out get
me in here
no he got a vest
where did the vest come from how was it
not a big event how did we not have a
vest event there's a whole deleted scene
where they build the vest they pour some
kind of molten leather into a you know a
big old mold I am upset that would have
been maybe one of the best scenes I know
it's okay maybe it'll be a flashback in
part two
or section four all right this is
looking cool
I mean no numbers we need to get to
seven
all right Z One strange
seven is not supposed to be open for
another week someone's updated the
algorithm
what
oh it's like activating
Geiger counters
I think it's your honest away like it's
way back home to charge it must return
to the charging dock
[Music]
okay
hey WC whatever it was up there the
loading hanger or something it said
it's just another day
[Music]
about that
oh my God is the hanger gonna move now
whoa cool so do you have to kill all the
Grievers and collect all eight
dang
uh okay who's going in the hole
Quavers
what the oh it's scanning he's
gonna be like no but maybe because they
have that thing
give me the whip I'll throw you the item
okay
oh
okay seven is now closing
[Music]
oh
nice job
[Music]
oh
whoa
right yes good okay oh
[Music]
wait this is like breaking up concrete
which like this this doesn't happen all
the time no they're gonna have to
completely redraw their map now
whoa
oh
my God
no this is terrible oh
no thank you
okay are we done yet
who are they expound yeah come on man
what's going on I still doors they
aren't closing oh now they want y'all to
go out there they're trying to shake
stuff up oh or that means all the
Grievers can get in now if they come out
at night it's grief would come out at
night uh grief is coming out at night
oh oh snap okay new entrance multiple
[Music]
all right now y'all are sitting ducks if
they can come from every sector you
gotta fight them off
what oh my God y'all better hurry come
on now
Teresa
can stop them oh man
oh
[Applause]
everybody
oh yeah select yourself in the old cage
oh
my goodness
I would start lighting stuff on fire and
see if that works burn the place to the
ground yeah
whoa holy to Molly
oh my God you gotta throw a fire stick
in its mouth yes yes yes molotovic
that's right Theresa you got great ideas
me and you girl girls get it done that's
what I'm talking about like some stuff
on fire
[Music]
behind me
oh my gosh it's like also a scorpion
yeah
oh good job they stuck it with stuff
[Music]
oh
I mean it was bound to happen oh no
Chuck not Chuck
Anyone But Chuck you better get him back
somebody stab that piece of metal with
something else
yeah come on y'all
yeah yeah get it Abby what's he gonna do
yeah pull that cord come on bro yes go
out yes
yes kill that hunk of metal
yeah
feel the rate
oh
[Music]
my goodness
Galley oh my God this freaking guy yep
he's one of them
one of them and they set him here
what happened before you got here maybe
he's right
Thomas stab yourself with it I need to
remember Teresa what are you gonna do to
remember
that's got to bring up some weird
feelings
put it
we don't know
are they all actually there or is it a
simulation
the Patricia Arquette
[Music]
did he program this whole thing God he's
taking control he said we had a choice
either join him or banish the Sundown
with you excellent It's not a prison
it's a test it all started when we were
kids they'd give us these challenges
they were experimenting on us no the
people who put you here I worked with
them the entire time you've been here I
was on the other side of it that is so
Grim why would they send us up if we
were with them
is the people we were before the maze
they don't even exist anymore these
creators took care of that and you must
have done something to make them put you
in here you went into the Maze and you
found a way out if I hang Albi would
still be alive sacrificed happens
man but I know that if he were here he
would be telling you the exact same
thing pick your ass up and finish what
you started oh I'll be here in spirit
what if Thomas is right maybe he can
lead us home we are home I'd love it
here you really think Vanishing us is
going to solve anything this isn't a
banishing it's an offering
what are you
oh my God
look at our Glade
this is the only way
and when the Grievers get what they came
here for oh we killed Galley now looking
like Samwise gamji over there do you
hear me I said time off I mean
all right guys step up yeah there we go
good good good good good
yeah nut kick get him sorry buddy
you don't have to come with us but we
are leaving anyone else who wants to
come that's your last chance just trying
to scare you no I'm not trying to scare
you you're already scared all right I'm
scared you have to be crazy not to be
scared
come with us good luck against the
gravers
all right you made your choice you take
this Chuck
stay behind us we get out now but we die
trying get rich or die trying all right
good for Green Bay
oh it's all spooky
how do you fight it
yes nice job guys
oh
my God somebody stab it in the eye stab
it in the mouth
yeah get its mouth come out
no no no no no under bits
[Music]
no Chuck
oh my god
get it please get it
yes
oh no oh no this is too much
[Music]
what
smart
[Music]
come on
yell that last number out yes
nice stab
what oh no oh poor guy
complete oh my goodness
oh bye bye scary spooky spider wow
[Music]
oh
gooey uh
well now we're just underground walking
through like to a concert I feel like
that's what it looks like yeah yeah
they'll be out in Sofi stadium in just a
second for the ears tour yeah we
remember those lights from his dream we
do
yup very clearly the exit love that
[Music]
oh no but the Grievers didn't get inside
right
what if it was Thomas Theresa killed
them all
maybe I gotta imagine Thomas was like
this is wrong we shouldn't do this and
then they put it in or something my name
is Dr Ava page I'm director of
operations of the world catastrophe
Killzone Department what if you're
watching this that means you've
successfully completed the maze trials I
wish I could be there in person to
congratulate you oh my it was all done
for a reason but the sun has scorched
our world
whoa millions of lives lost to fire
famine suffering by global scale while
warming this movie's woke
what came after it was worse we called
it the flare oh no a deadly virus that
attacks the brain it is violent
unpredictable
oh yeah
in time a new generation emerged that
could survive the virus suddenly there
was a reason to hope for a cure oh
they're all those the young would have
to be tested all in an effort to
understand
huh
you realize it but you're very important
you're all the special unfortunately
your trials have only just begun as
you'll no doubt soon discover not
everyone agrees with her methods the
it may be too late for us
oh God remember she's getting a shot
right on camera
oh
that was 45 minutes ago
supposed to do now get out go outside oh
God they gotta walking in the scorched
Earth okay
no
there he goes there he is Kelly don't
you can't leave oh there's no escape
from this place
has he been out there has he seen the
world as it is I belong to the maze
what's Chuck thinking we all do oh
no damn oh that was a good faker
oh damn it
no
yeah
you're gonna kiss them yourself remember
I told you that you're gonna die an old
woman warm in your bed
I mean where did Chuck go I've never
seen him before he's good
oh
who are these people coming in
legit bad about that
whoa okay into the sand on the outside
of the building I feel like it said
Wicked did it
don't worry
safe now what is going on was that their
their acronym wckd yes Wicked are they
saying that their organization is good
oh yeah yeah okay
oh my God I'd say Wicked shelter
oh
my God I think it's safe to say the maze
trials were a complete success Thomas
continues to surprise and impress love
that guy so let's move forward it's time
now to begin
phase two what is that what does that
mean what is the sequel called what
Grim world were all those scientists
faking dead because that means they had
to fake dead for a long time now to rig
each other up with squibs
firing guns what in the tomorrow their
own lab exactly yeah break everything up
okay well this has just left me with a
lot of questions more questions what do
you mean yeah it's all wrapped up here
Tara it's not James Dashner only wrote
One novel I assume I know that's not
true I'm gonna say I did not read this
book okay I had no idea what was going
on I thought at first maybe I did I did
not
um this
was intense I really liked it yeah
Galley was a real pain in the ass
uh which yeah I get it he was our like
he was playing playing the role but
um yeah I still have a lot of questions
that um went unanswered but I do think
it's cool at the end that you're like oh
see I was like I was this so they are
kind of like clones but not clones
they're experiments and they're the only
ones who can survive the virus I guess
he messed up he messed up okay give us
give us the juice John what'd you think
I enjoyed it overall I mean yeah it's
definitely one of those movies that
clearly is setting up for much more uh
lower and many more twists and turns to
come so like yeah it's you know it ends
fully on a note of like oh we've just
scraped the iceberg
um but yeah for the immediacy of what it
was I was always intrigued and I was
always kind of gripped by it I mean like
you know you have this
very compelling Central mystery of like
what's in the freaking maze you know
like what's what's going on out there
what does this all mean and so
I think a movie like this in certain
ways uh
benefits greatly off that sense of
mystery and certainly by the end they do
give you more mystery to look forward to
um but yeah I mean it's one of those
things where sort of like once you're
out you're like okay yeah so the
monsters were out there and then we just
kind of had to find the right uh you
know sequence of mcguffins and things
and yeah and then we're able to break it
like it's it's more linear and
straightforward than it presents itself
to be which is yeah like it was going to
be like a bait and switch like you
thought it was gonna have like more of a
like tricky reveal I thought it was
gonna blow my mind or something yeah and
like it's cool like it's I'm not like
griping at it for not having like some
like amazing on expected twists right
um but yeah I mean like knowing again
the lane that this originates from and
knowing that a lot of those stories tend
to be some kind of dystopian apocalyptic
Society maybe there's an ecological
angle like you know I mean all that
stuff is kind of fun and interesting as
a reveal like oh the Earth has been
scorched and we gotta you know
like it's it begs a lot of questions in
terms of like okay so this is like a
shelter thing but they're running this
game and it seems like part of the game
is Carnage and so like yeah it leaves
you with questions certainly which again
is most likely by Design it's one of
those things where I find myself
wondering how the sequels will play out
and if they will deliver on getting more
interesting versus versus like you know
kind of laying groundwork right now or
will it plummet like will it fall into
being like okay like here's a dystopian
sci-fi thing of like a bunch of young
people leading a resistance that I've
you know kind of seen a lot of times
before yeah that we've seen before yes
like having the Maze and having you know
the isolation of like we're in the Glade
and like you know we can stay here
everything's fine or we can go out into
this crazy unknown Turf and uh and so
without that you know I'm sure they'll
come up with something else I'm sure
that they're there's a reason why it's a
popular series yeah but yeah it kind of
you know runs its course for the maze
itself and uh I don't know like like
Part of Me Maybe wish that we could have
seen some of the real like unknowns of
the maze yeah like I kind of thought
right with the number that was on the
thing that or mixed with like the maze
numbers which yes that came in at the
end which we assumed but I kind of
thought like maybe it would be like a
reveal like oh the way for us to get out
the secret is like us is like uh us like
the people that they would have had I
don't know especially with Thomas and
Therese like remembering they're the
ones who remembered stuff they came up
at the end I get that they were working
on it smart like we kept doing here but
um I don't know I felt like there there
would be but I know the book's already
written but there would be like a reveal
that like I don't know that the secret
was like in them and they had to like
figure figure more out I don't know I I
I did like I love the relationship
between
um him and Chuck and I like that a lot
uh I I didn't get as sad as I think I
maybe would have because it's probably
not enough time to really build up his
relationship with Chuck but in the book
I bet you there is right I would have
cried when Chuck died if I was reading
the book but for some reason it didn't
it hit me trust me it did I just didn't
like it didn't hit me super hard like
maybe it could have if there was a
little more of a build up but um you got
to get to the action so I get it oh yeah
and it's one of those like very end sort
of like Bleak World Stingers of like oh
and I thought that maybe there was going
to be some kind of Greater reveal with
Gally maybe that he was like the plant
all along yeah making sure they don't
try they don't leave or maybe he knows
what's outside and he hasn't let on why
like he is so attached to being in the
Glade but yeah but yeah it mostly at
least here in this execution reads like
ah we just need one more like you know
heart crushing sting of some sort to
just remind you that uh you know certain
things are just too good for this harsh
world and Chuck is one of them yeah I
would have liked it if at the end if he
had remembered what was out there and
how life was shitty and he's like
confessing that like it was really hard
for him out there and it sucked and this
is who I wants to be here and this is
like this is me reimagining the movie
and he's crying and he's like this is
the only family I found is here in this
box you know and then they're like oh
man poor Galley he's just a jerk because
he had a hard life I don't know
something like that yeah it like and I'm
sure I don't know I don't think we'll
get any more sort of expounding on that
and like again it's it's not a a major
complaint of mine because again part of
the charm of a movie like this is that
you're just thrust into a situation you
don't know much about anybody but yeah
like for as much as that what like
without that becoming a moment of
Greater personal significance it does
feel sort of like one final gotcha
because you know I mean true I don't
know I thought there could have been
some kind of Arc or some kind of thing
with him where you know it's like oh I
was wrong or I followed you guys out
please you know like accept me or
something or please let me come along
true like wait up for me yeah I don't
know like that I thought that that yeah
that that ending beat could have been
more rich in character stuff that would
have made it more feel a little less
like a puppy killing yeah you know
that's true to make sure that you know
Thomas becomes that much more hardened
next time yeah and you know I mean like
Teresa certainly interesting presence
not much of a character that's like
another thing that I'm like what the
heck like she was just like there and
she came with a note and then we didn't
really give her any more juice than that
yeah and it's again I know the the
counter will probably be like well in
the sequel she's going to be a lot more
important yeah but yeah for the
execution here if I only saw this movie
I would be like I kind of want to get to
know her a little bit better yeah um or
you know establish some kind of
connection you know because they have
the whole thing about like we know each
other we used to work right across from
each other but it's it's only kind of a
just one of many details touched upon
that's touched upon and left in the like
very quickly yeah and it's like all the
maze stuff is is cool the effects are
neat like the idea is really cool and I
think you know you can't make this like
a two and a half hour movie necessarily
but you know it's once you're on the
other side of it I think it's that it's
like since they already have the whole
place mapped out I get the utility of
that plot choice but at the same time
I'm like we could like learn about I
don't know because like we are we're
doing it through Dylan O'Brien's
perspective but at the same time I don't
know it's it's pretty straight I guess
that's what I keep coming back to is
like for as much as this seems like
straightforward linear puzzle yeah it's
pretty straightforward and I think too
it's like once he goes into the Maze and
figures it out you know what to kind of
look for and and you know kills the
Reaver uh griever and all that stuff
you know that pretty much sets you
directly on the path whereas me I'm
sitting here going well there are like
eight quadrants they all must be
different or are they all or or you know
is it just like any one of these could
have been the exit you know why is it
that they found the ones like they found
number seven first and number seven is
the exit it's what they thought about I
thought they were gonna do something
like that where it's like oh it's just
the next level of the game but it's not
the it's not the exit and spiritually
that's true because at the end Patricia
Clarkson's like you know I wish I could
tell you this is Dan but this is just
the beginning
um but you know like we're out into the
world now so like I don't know the the
unless they're gonna prison break this
and find a way to maneuver them into a
new Maze and this is just a future that
deals with its problems be amazed it's
just a scorched Earth with multiple
mazes on it and they just throw children
in there you're like good luck yeah and
I thought you know the the idea of the
whole like Wicked is good thing you know
was an interesting Mantra to kind of get
you thinking about human nature and then
by the end you're like oh it must be
that you know this organization or the
good guys maybe and we shouldn't trust
the people who are in rescuing the kids
right now right
um but I don't know this idea of like I
thought that's what it said on the
outside was like Wicked uh shelter
shelter or something like that and and
guys
wicked as their acronym was the world
they're funny like earmarks to be that
do very much again hearken to you know
the fun of a why a novel adaptation
because yeah it's all about it is good
we got the cool terminology all of our
different lore that we're gonna set up
for you in a you know yeah and uh you
know it for an immediate I think I
enjoyed the immediate experience of this
quite a bit and I enjoyed the movie in
hindsight once it was concluded look at
that was pretty good it was yeah it was
fun and it was you know intriguing but
um it's gonna you know like the sequel
or whatever is gonna have to like really
kind of set itself apart from various
other like the world has been destroyed
and working and now we have to go yeah
you know yeah like it it's that I think
is like the the early parts of the movie
have you going like this is really
fascinating and I'm not even thinking
about other stories like this and then
when you get to the end I'm like now I'm
thinking of a lot of other stories yeah
yeah yeah it's true I feel like the
writer was like he was thinking about a
phrase that people would use after they
read his book and it's everybody who has
the book and they're like
yeah you know that that's what they're
doing and like yeah I'm like oh that's
probably their inside thing like I'm
surprised in 2014 I didn't see like
teenagers walking around with t-shirts
to say Wicked it's good but then I might
have been like you mean the musical or
you know it might have been confusing
yeah or just you know Boston slang again
anyway I give it it means good it means
good and I'll give it I'll give it us a
seven out of ten what do you give it
John lay down 6.5 maybe because yeah
we're probably in the same spot I was
gonna I was gonna go out of five and say
like you know three three and a half
like it's pretty good yeah pretty good
like I thought it was well assembled I
thought it was really I agree yeah like
I thought the performers all did a
really nice job I thought the way they
you know established the world of their
Camp was really nice
um I I liked a lot of the details of how
they were living and how they shot a lot
of this the intensity and just the way
they cap captured a lot of the effects
and a lot of the action sequences felt
appropriately yeah thrilling and
harrowing and intense and whatnot and
again in you know when you're still deep
in the mystery I was really intrigued by
that stuff so I think like you know
behind the camera there was a lot of
good work going yeah that's true um and
then yeah you know as a as an actual
story you know this is all right pretty
good yeah I think it's like I always
think in my head I go to story but then
I was like oh man but those scenes with
the spiders like John's remember like
remembering it more than me but now I'm
like I'm in it and I'm like those were
pretty dope those are awesome and I'm
like what are those things like yeah did
you guys make these for these trials or
this is this part of the immunity thing
like you know did you like capture a few
mod them out and then you know because
this seems like it was all because of of
you know global warming weather
catastrophes yeah so what accounts for
these creatures are they purely yours is
there something else that work there
again I'm sure we'll find out in his
sequel but we want to know now but yeah
there are ways in which this could have
felt like a more well-rounded Movie
experience on its own yeah like a more
well-rounded story yeah yeah all right
well we did it we watched it we liked it
we'll probably
next one and letting us know if we
should watch the next one I would also
be happy to watch the next one I mean we
should just we should just do it and
then be like well we'll we'll all watch
it together we'll all decide but you
guys should also be like you should
watch the next one but don't do any
spoilers in case we are going to yeah
yeah and what else do I say in closing
John I want to see react to other things
I just told you about
um I think we're good I think you want
to shout out a patreon really quick
before we get out of here let's do that
thing let's do it
Anisa I'll leave uh there's only one
girl in the movie but now you're the
second well Tara's here too but yeah
you girls involved with the Maze Runner
experience today and if we were caught
in the Maze I would absolutely want you
on our team because you are a caring
person but you're also a person who
knows your way around you know like
health and Medicine type things oh and
also you're just the kind of person who
is tenacious you know if we had to
figure the maze out I feel like you
would keep us on track that would be
good feeling good morale High yeah and
she'd also be able to heal wounds or
something yeah yeah that's good and if
we found out later that you were
secretly involved with you know like
experimenting on stuff like I would I
would be willing to give you the benefit
of the doubt I would just kill you
I mean also valid I'm gonna have to
protect you from Tara and that's also
what this shout out is for is just to
let you know you know that uh you should
watch your back too it's like man you
were in there you were doing experience
with these spiders in the Maze I'm like
I'm not I know nope that's some BS like
you gotta go you know
so
whatever I guess when we we're pushing
you out into the maze now but keep your
Pledge on file because that's what
really this is all definitely keep it
and if we ever meet in person he's your
buddy and I guess maybe I'm not but if
you're watching if we watch another
movie though and like we do another
shout out ways from now like it might be
a different story with you Anisa you
know then we could be friends again so
you got to keep your patronage so like
we can see where our relationship goes
friendship wise you know I like that
idea yeah that's a good idea right maybe
you'll come out of the other side as
friends yeah you never know kill me oh
the other side of the rainbow boom
appreciate you we'll see you there I
love you Nisa love you bye peace